[Music]
hey guys we wanted to pop right in
before this episode of ear biscuits to
let you know that we will not be hosting
this episode of ear biscuits that's
right actually Stevie's hosting this one
yes she's interviewing Alex right
because we're calling this a crew
biscuit yeah because we're gonna have a
handful of crew biscuits take out your
hand open it up do it
this helps to visualize vigil eyes open
up your hand open your palm and receive
some little biscuits some little crew
biscuits you can fit you can fit a
handful of them in your hand starting
with this one because we are we
literally just ran from the set of buddy
system briskly walked well it's hot out
there so I wanted to get in okay and
we're gonna run back right after this
and we're gonna we're gonna keep
shooting baa baa black season - I'll
walk back - but we're having a great
time I'm gonna trot it's not affecting
anything about us personal appearance or
anything like that no nothing are being
impacted by this by this season of buddy
system we're having a great time it's
going very well but it is taking all of
our time plus a little extra that we
don't have mmm-hmm
so that's why we were excited about the
crew stepping in crazy let's talk about
buddy system for just a second just to
come to load up sees it's crazy I mean
like I mean everything every every scene
we do I say I'm still like they're gonna
come in they're gonna shut this down
someone someone would sense
we shouldn't be allowed to do that he's
gonna say stop the madness lots of
people are conjecturing about different
aspects of the plot given some of the
social media that has been released and
also the behind-the-scenes videos that
you can watch on that this is mythical
YouTube channel yeah you know what
you're not gonna I mean the plot is so
stupid no don't say stop me in a good
way okay good stupid I mean people see
an image and they're like wait this must
happen I was like no what you think is
happening probably not happen I'm
telling you that's great you got to
watch it to figure out what's happening
yeah yeah so even though we're so busy
doing that it was very important that
thought never crossed our mind to not
put an intro on the top of this to set
up Stevie and her conversation with Alec
of utmost importance as we thought that
it was almost crucial yet sensual that
we that we do that intro yeah we would
we would never not do an intro for this
although they would have to then do an
intro without us having to do although I
will say you don't want we will not do
other intros for the rest of the the
crew biscuits that's probably it was
very very important for us to do this
one just so you'll know that that's what
is coming but for the next few we will
not be doing an intro because you're
smart people mythical beasts are smart
they don't have to have everything
explained to them right and I think that
you're gonna you're gonna gain insight
into the lives of the people that we
work with and that are our friend friend
workers they're not just co-workers
everywhere in workers right I do think
they're friends linked no they're not
friends let's be real I mean they're
their friends because they work for us
yeah but now they've become friend but
we do like them a lot people become
friends through different circumstances
in life you don't have to say well
you're only a friend because but if they
didn't watch shows you as a friend they
never stay in work force they wouldn't
be on I mean you were a classmate of
mine before you were a friend I was it
was circumstance that led us together in
his circumstance that has led us to the
mythical crew it's nothing to be ashamed
of I'm not gonna call him friend workers
I'm not calling friendly workers they
are fair friendly when they were that
they I'm gonna call him friends friends
I'm also gonna call you friends enjoy
this crew biscuit
[Music]
welcome to Crewe biscuits I'm Stevie and
I'm Alex and today we are taking over
the table of dim lighting amidst buddy
system preparation pulling back that
production curtain of magic
to let you in on that little secret if
you didn't already guess that one
mmm-hmm
I'm going to now give a double intro
because we're not sure if at this point
more production magic rhettandlink are
doing an intro to this intro so you
never know this isn't the case that they
are doing an intro cool wow that was a
great intro that went well better than
expected and all the nice things that
they said about you about me
that was great of them it was just like
super generous and heartfelt and I cried
yeah it was beautiful
more than more than I could have asked
for yeah yeah okay this is in case I
didn't do an intro okay uh you know what
I was hoping for this week on ear
biscuits what what's that an intro from
rhettandlink yeah that's what is it nice
it would have been great and I think it
would have kicked things off in a much
better way had there been an intro but
because there's not an intro yeah is
what we're talking about sure is there
not an intro right alright I think that
covered it nailed it like always
nailed it um so what is what is crew
biscuits you might be asking because you
didn't put together the fact that we're
members of the mythical crew and we're
on air biscuits
yep let me just explain uh I would like
to start off by just talking about
myself because that's what you do when
you have a guest on is that you just
talk about yourself
mhm I never have a second to talk to any
mythical crew members I'm physically
running oftentimes I've noticed I'm the
only one who physically runs from
meeting to meeting but I do it and I
wanted to have a second to sit down with
crew members and just talk about life
and where they're they're coming from
where they're coming from currently
where they're coming I just came from
the bathroom
so that went pretty well so Alex you're
my first you're my first guess yeah do
you feel honored very um excited nervous
sweaty you're gonna be great though do
you want to know why I chose you as my
first guest I do it's a heartfelt moment
just like the intro that rhettandlink
maybe did people cry on the show and it
could happen again let's see um well
I've always said to you time and time
again your greatest skill is just
talking to people and this is a podcast
yeah well first of all thank you that's
very nice
you've talked some people into some
really odd things yeah horrible well
they horrible but some wild things yeah
and you're always like sure I'll call
that snake charmer ask him if he does
lizards yeah you never know until you
ask
so traditional ear biscuits we go way
back yeah um I I have a list of things
that I know about you facts that I know
one of the facts that I think everyone
knows is that you're from Michigan
mm-hmm you went to Michigan yeah you
love Michigan yeah you where Michigan
hat all the time uh you have parents in
Michigan yes you have a brother who is
from Michigan still there yeah yeah tell
me tell me about your family life tell
me about Alex and Michigan Michigan was
a great place to grow up
my whole family is still in Michigan my
sister lives in Michigan as well she's a
nurse I have a brother who's a doctor
we're talking about city like urban
Michigan are we talking about corn
fields corn fields everywhere a corn
field in front of my house a corn field
behind my house dead serious cornfield
to the right of my house and a corn
field to left my house we're on the
rounded bike I'll show you a picture on
like Google Maps after this if you zoom
in it's just cornfields and then my
house did you have anything to do with
no so here's what happened my dad is a
professor of computer science and
engineering so a big computer guy you
know really into all that kind of tech
stuff a professor at at Michigan State
so another college in Michigan okay a
rival school the one that I went to but
he's you know very technologically savvy
guy but he was tired of like living on
campus I think mhm and so he moved to
the countryside just outside of college
this is pre you being born or this is
like you used to live on a college yeah
so I grew like I think until I was like
five or six I grew up on a college
campus and then we moved to the
countryside okay like my dad would have
like drunk college students pee on our
lawn and stuff he would have them well
he wouldn't he wouldn't be like hey what
are you doing but that would happen to
him and so he would come over tonight
because my lawn to move and I would love
for you to pee my want no yeah it was
like he lived in the middle of a very
crazy college town and then you know he
moves my family to the countryside but
he continued to work yeah yeah exactly
okay and he's still doing that today or
yeah okay women in the cornfield living
in the cornfield working on computers
okay like he's like really big-time
computer guy they're like he does like
super computing stuff did he growing up
my dad always had like one of his
hobbies was he had a bunch of PCs and
he'd take them all apart and then he'd
build like super computers that did like
very random things but he was he like a
hobbyist computer guy or just a huge
he's like hardcore like that's his job
so he do like it's not a game to build
PI you would do like I mean we would
always grow up with which I thought it
was strange so back in the day you know
now everybody has computers but when I
was a kid not that many people did it
yeah we had four or five in our house
all the time PC yeah yeah all kinds of
different stuff so it was a little bit
different but yeah he was
they were always everywhere around the
house was he like a gamer dude he would
play like flight simulator yes your dad
do that yeah
that was a great game though yeah it's
also no joke it's like you're in a
cockpit yeah
and like a huge joystick yeah he had the
whole thing I think it was gonna be
bringing up huge everybody here we are
here we are and now let me tell you my
dad could work it you know you creepy
you could really fly that thing
you know yeah I mean now I do yeah yeah
sure
guessing your mom was not into flight
simulation no okay I think my like
takeout for my mom a lot more like my
dad's very analytical you know kind of a
more serious guy but my mom is a school
counselor she also loves like what age
like what elementary middle school okay
so she's always dealing with like
children's problems and stuff you know
that's her thing
yes yeah she's sang the song about a
volcano to us like if you're angry and
you're about to blow your top I don't
know it I wish I did I don't know it I
know I'm sorry Laurie punch definitely
has sang the volcano sign though this is
when we cut to the video of your mom
singing she was definitely she would
definitely send one in she loves it but
knows yes she had like a lot of
problem-solving techniques she liked to
yeah we would always say we're being
counselled like mom don't counsel us
what so you have a brother and a sister
and what's the age difference between
all of you guys my brother and I like
almost two years apart like a year and
three quarters as the older yeah he's
older than me and then my sisters three
years younger than me okay yeah a middle
kid no no it's good I like me JFK was a
middle child but you middle children
it's that people forget about them
that's that yeah so were you ever
forgotten yeah I was left in a theme
park no no no I mean they do not leave
you at home and they're like no his
name's Alex no no I mean I don't think
there's a unique experience to be in a
middle kid though you know you're never
like the center of attention ever I
think you're always competing for it
right yeah I am the oldest child and my
sister I have one sister and she's
younger than I am and I felt like
growing up she my mom would like test
things out on me and then a couple years
later she'd be like yes you can watch
pg-13 movies or you can like I never got
to do any of the fun stuff like I was
always the guarded one and then my
sister got to be the one that just got
to do everything always yeah I think it
was a thing where they're like
they gave it a shot with my brother and
then he gave up on me then I was like
yeah by the time my sister came around
they're like yeah maybe we should give
it a shot again you know but you know to
each their own experience just got
married yeah
and how was how was that it was why
where was that Michigan yeah it was back
in Michigan I was like last week yeah it
was great I was my best my brother's
best man it was my best man I was the
best man I could be at that wedding I
wanted to talk one of my notes says hold
on I need to read it directly because
it's a funny one it says mother -
protein start - veggie mom question mark
do you know what that note means no
what's that about growing up I felt like
my mom liked dinner for me always
included a protein a starch and a veggie
and it was like a very it's a very like
50s thing to do it wouldn't be like peas
as the vegetable but like in my mind as
a child growing up if I didn't have
those three things something had gone
wrong no one had like it had been a bad
day for my mom yeah so I think this
means did you have protein starch and
veggies for your like what was your
that's home life like yeah kinda so we
my mom would patch or pack our lunches
every day mm-hmm and we would always
it'd be like a sandwich drink like
starchy snack and then like a sweet
snack like I put her bag in a paper bag
every day so yeah you have the same
thing for lunch every day or was it like
a varied sandwich situation very like it
changed all the time but it was always
the same thing and be like I feel like
goldfish are ruined for me really
because you used to get them all time I
can't I feel that yeah I used to get so
it'd be like a sandwich and then like a
pudding and then like some chips and
then a drink and I remember it pretty
clearly cuz like you'd see these kids
with Lunchables and stuff like that and
I'd be like lately no but about they're
just incredible I could believe it yeah
no but that makes sense cuz it's like
like you said we'd get
same kind of thing every time yeah I
guess my mom is a starch I keep wanting
to go like this but then my um then I'm
you know the mic is wait taller than I
am
yeah and this looks weird and it looks
like so I read like this are we talking
like public school yeah
public school the whole all your
schooling way through yeah but I don't
know I think it's probably a different
experience than a lot of people because
I lived in the middle of nowhere so it
was like there there was only one school
to go to did people write on horses to
get to school nobody would take their
tractors to school they would yeah like
mulch in the parking lot multiple
tractors I think they like if it was
like in season they would roll up in
their Specter and be like hey what's up
like and also if it was deer hunting
season like there's no point going to
school cuz all the kids were gone I
thought you're gonna bring tractors into
it because they were always shooting
beers on deers is on their tractor
pickup trucks in my part oh yeah a lot
of those this kit I like cuz hanging out
in the parking lot in high school was
like a thing yeah it was cool before the
bell yeah and I remember after school
one day this kid was chasing after his
friend like like he was running and his
friend was driving I think was like a
station wagon or something and he
stopped the station wagon to be funny
and the kitchen master knew it ran
through the back windshield
yikes that's I don't know why I just he
passed away he passed away
no he's since that incident during the
incident okay good I would not have
brought up that story but um but I don't
remember who the kid is and therefore I
haven't spoken to him so I our IP if
that is I hope you're doing well the
case did you have like an iconic car in
high school cuz I do
let me hear about your oh yeah I had so
I done 96 Jeep Cherokee is that an
iconic car
well mine what's the DEF mine so my car
like I had this 90s there's just this
red Jeep but everything was broken on it
basically so all the doors like they
wouldn't lock is this a car you asked
for is this no laying down
me and my brother would share it okay
but none of the doors would lock so
every day I would come out of school and
all of my stuff in my car would be on my
roof and all the doors would be open my
friends thought I was super funny but
also this is great you know like though
back windshield sprayer mm-hmm mine was
broken which shoe outwards and so like
my friends were backed by and I would
shoot them in the face of my shield
wiper fluid but yeah it was pretty
people knew that iconic yeah good times
in that car I had a blue rav4 ooh but it
was not iconic but that's all it was my
roof or anything like that I love that
cars guy I'm not a big car person I feel
like I like I've had the same car since
2000 I've known you
yeah yeah and I you're you are a big car
person sort of I mean sort of a chooser
of cars yeah chooser of cars like if you
asked the specs about my car I could not
tell you thing about it other than it's
red and the roof comes off of that thing
who was a who know you can call him a ho
he was he had a lot of personality he
wasn't a PT Cruiser no a heavily
misunderstood chevy HHR
yeah okay but that car I mean that car
was great here we use that car for
shoots all the time do you go Jeep HHR
red convertible yeah we're moving up
broken Jeep Chevy HHR and then I got my
red convertible so you took the Jeep to
Michigan to University of Michigan or
you took the hhrg I didn't have a car I
didn't have a car in Michigan at U of M
but I got one when I got my
job after I graduate I got the HR did
you always wanted to go to U of M no
well it's weird I don't I don't know if
I've talked about this a lot but I
didn't go right to U of M right away I
was a transfer still yeah I spent a year
scandal I'm not a pureblood U of M guy I
went to school for a year at this place
called Eastern Michigan University which
is which is we it's weird it's like
three miles from U of M but it's also d1
school but it's uh-huh men I don't it's
not as good of a school is a great
school I don't know how to walk around
things they're watching you when you're
ya know so it's fine yeah you're right
yeah it wasn't as good at school
but it was cool I mean yeah I spent a
year at Eastern I didn't really know
what I wanted to do so like I said my
dad taught at Michigan State I probably
could have gone to Michigan State which
is also a big you know it was next year
house right next to my yeah it's
literally like 10 minutes away from
where I grew up but that's kind of the
thing so like all my friends would go to
Michigan State we would go there when
we're in high school still and hang out
with our friends like I tell everybody
did so everybody kind of did would do
the same thing like a lot of my friends
from high school are still all best
friends I don't really I don't talk to
them unless they are watching actually
probably sorry but yeah everyone would
kind of do the same thing and I never
liked doing the same thing so I went
farther away I went to Eastern Michigan
you turn Michigan University I never
even applied to U of M because it's
really good school hard to get into and
then I transfer out after year I got in
your self-confidence I feel like I feel
like you've grown and your car choices
so but once you were at U of M yeah then
you decided you wanted to be
entertainment yeah yeah well I was at U
of M I I started studying film and kind
of fell into some really lucky
internships and stuff like that working
on movies I would work on every summer I
was at U of M I would work on like
another movie like real movies you know
what my favorite movie story of yours is
probably do you want to talk about your
you're streaming my screaming yeah so
sorry sorry I'm jumping around but
you're at U of M yes I do you want to go
into film yeah you fall into some good
internships let's maybe talk about those
internships and then we'll talk about
the the screaming well it was weird so
right when I got to school these huge
tax breaks were coming to Michigan like
over fifty five percent tax break to
shoot a movie in Michigan okay so you
could double your budget by just
shooting in Detroit which is like kind
of a bombed-out City as is like it's a
Detroit listening uh but a beautiful
bombed out City it's like World War two
never stopped but it's beautiful there
it's great I love Detroit but anyways
yeah so there's these huge tax breaks so
there was tons of movies being filmed in
Michigan and there they didn't have
enough people to work on them which is
crazy it's like that's people's dreams
that work on these huge budget movies
but that's summer 2010 and 2011 long
long ago but yeah so there's all these
these tons of movie shooting and so
there'd be these job postings all the
time like hey we need people to come out
but they would never say what it's for
they're always like very secretive they
didn't want like press people finding
out stuff so I applied my first one I
applied to was like intern needed to
assist with directors and producers and
I was like I could do that probably and
then like I got to this random kind of
office building in Ann Arbor and like
the there was a parking sign that said
parking for Wes Craven's like oh snap
this is so crazy I just reacted as if
that was a surprise who's at the parking
sign coming that's pretty wild
especially a kid from you know for
cornfields around his house to be like
in the presence of like I loved movies
that's why I studied movies and so to be
around all that was crazy at what I was
20 20 years old so what so after you saw
the parking spot I went in and like they
sat me down directly in Wes Craven's
office and said like oh this is going to
be internship working with
his assistants and the producers of the
movie like is that something interested
in I was like ah yeah yeah sure it would
be great and then kind of like one thing
led to another
it's kind of weird but I was working on
like a fifty five million dollar movie
in the middle of Ann Arbor like that
summer it's crazy so crazy as well but
you weren't just working on the movie
behind the scenes no well no I am
featured heavily SF I actually got a
check for cocky student which was my
role in the movie sorry jump ahead but
yeah recently you did yeah like last
week I got a $13 check in the mail
that's not too shabby no in a while
check it out on Netflix tell your
friends to watch it as well because I
didn't think I get some percentage of
money every time people watch it I guess
we can't really cut the clip though I
would I would tell myself watching this
yeah we couldn't catch it if you want
you probably could find it somewhere but
yeah that's another weird story so I was
like strangely I'd become sort of
friends with Wes like he was an 80 year
old man and he left playing Angry Birds
and flappy bird or not flappy bird
there was doodle doodle it is the
difference between Angry Bird and what's
flappy bird flappybird is when you press
it and then it tries to go in between
like bars and it's not an angry bird no
it's me a happy bird I would say he
loves to fly oh sorry I'm getting this
whatsapp this is the absolute um and I'm
reminded via Cody going like this how
much I desired to have an ad right now
Alex are you desiring an ad I would love
to see an advertisement and then we are
forward the video portion of this and
you know what I would like to talk about
yeah what rhettandlink.com/store I've
been there it's good I love it we have
new good mythical summer merch we have
sunglasses we have t-shirts we have
beach towels we have it's so much so
many things Alex you seem to be pointing
at your left nipple no yes it's a ten
feet tall shirt which is
also available there yeah these are
available there they taste like butter
too and and and other logo pocket tees
everything your mythical heart could
desire you can find at
rhettandlink.com/store
that's our h88 indie link oh it's
link2cell imk how do you spell stores
like oh god let's just I guess what was
cut early yeah well just cut okay oh my
gosh wow that was really good
I can't believe how great they were at
spelling those two yeah they were good
actors - um okay what were we just
talking about I'm acting oh my gosh that
was so good speaking of acting yes
you're rolling scream for ya um there is
another story that you have told me that
I want to bring up because I think that
if you brought it up it would sound like
your name dropping but if you I bring it
up it is exciting
so um Miley Cyrus tell me about her
well okay so after I did scream and I
had a rolling scream for will breeze
over that I was in scream for a kid was
too young to do it and so they asked me
to do it
wait that's not cocky student that's a
different that is cocky soon this is
like the story of khakis do that
oh I'm sorry there's more okay so yes we
talked about that and now we're going
play-by-play on cocky student yeah to
give you two because we're not done with
cocky so I just uh yeah you in detention
on say yeah want to join me no so I was
I was funny at the time and I guess the
kid that they had hired to play that had
lied about his age
and he was underage and it was like a
sag project so they were like oh you
can't do it
mm-hmm and so that day they needed
somebody to replace it and they're like
Alex worry you're not doing anything you
need to do this and I was like oh god
are you serious and so I went into like
a dark hallway hallway with Wes and he
was like walk up and say this line to me
and I did it and he was like yeah that's
fine I was like oh snap
and so the next thing I was like
inherent makeup I was in I had like in
my own trailer for the day very very
well I lived insane so I'm I was grossed
I was working on a set I remember like
going back to the hair people and she
was like fine was the last time you
showered I was like so long I'm on this
set every day you know that Wow yes she
was rude and I had like really curly
hair I don't know it's a wild look
really naturally had curly hair they
didn't curl your hair no I mean I I
think I was like they shower you is that
what you're saying they like bathe they
sponge makeup sponge bath your body yeah
yeah it was gross yeah I just looked
crazy and then they did what they could
I think and then I had to go do that
line and it was weird I feel like
students look yeah yeah yeah exactly
curly hair yeah all students have curly
hair yeah but yeah that was the story
though I had curly hair I wasn't hired
to be an actor I was just there right
time right place I played a lot of
doodle jump with West and yeah flappy
bird you're in between bars they're
happy and they're not angry yep yeah
doodle doodle doodle is just a guy sound
old doodle jumps no no yeah this is like
early early iPhone games and I had just
gotten an iPhone to like my parents had
got me an iPhone for that movie that's
like a neat one everyone will think I'm
a loser if I'm on this movie I don't
have an iPhone and so I just gotten like
it was like doodle jump on the iPhone
Wes and I had bonded over that and then
he asked me to do that part and I was in
it you owe it all to doodle gems yes I
gave a really good teaser earlier yeah
when I just said Miley Cyrus
that's all I said she's great what how
did she come into play this is another
film that you worked on because there
were not a lot of people in Michigan to
work on films yeah so I killed it you
know I'm the I'm the best guy around
after I work with Wes Craven I'm like
top notch now there's nobody here would
really worked on movies and then the
next summer came around and they were
like looking for people again and I was
like I happen to be closed due to jump
friends with Wes Craven so perhaps I
could work on this film as well so I
worked for this that's like the perfect
cover letter yeah it was wild so I work
for this guy named chip Dickens on an
independent movie called love and honor
and chip Dickens was like a former
executive at Paramount and he like had
left there and he's doing independent
films now directing producing he was
like I think he was a higher-up at
Disney as well but he was like hardcore
like I love he's like one of the best
dudes ever like he kind of was a huge
mentor to me and still is like great
great dude but he hired me for that
movie and on that return PA as his
assistant I was an assistant to the
executive producer and you're still in
school this is like yes summer between
you being in school
yeah I'm 21 so this is the next summer
after scream 4 okay and so Liam
Hemsworth was the lead in that movie
this is like right after he had done was
not oh gosh I almost had Twilight which
is wrong it's the other one I wouldn't
call that one it's the other one it's a
with you know Hunger Games Hunger Games
yeah yeah which is also good we're young
which the movie Hunger Games is great
yeah it's or it's good that we know of
Hunger Games both were smart young and
we know about stuff I like Hunger Games
yeah he's Peeta or Gayle one of those no
he's not Peeta and I like Hunger Games
to the point where I know that he's well
maybe now I'm questioning myself but I
know Jennifer Lawrence yeah okay oh that
was a oh my gosh I totally forgot I
wanted us to have a platform to do shout
outs because I feel like we never do if
we're on GMM sure we're you know ten
feet tall like I'm always on ten feet
tall and I'm always thinking
you know when am I gonna get a chance to
shout out and then I so I want to give a
shout out to Jennifer Lawrence um thank
you for being in Hunger Games yes
and you're really cool it seemed cool I
feel like I've wasted my shout out
moment I do one yeah I want to shout out
to Liam Hemsworth all also in Hunger
Games who is a great guy I love that guy
very very sweet dude was very nice to me
as a young man I appreciate you love you
and your assistant Angus both great
people love you miss you hang out soon
that was very it was very personal
yeah whereas mine was just more of an
observation I'm sorry yeah I shouldn't
have done it that's fine um yeah okay so
Liam Hemsworth is in it and he's a nice
guy and you know his assistant Angus
yeah Oh his assistant Angus is the best
but oh he's great too everyone's so fun
but yeah so I I worked on that movie and
somehow also became like friends with
with Liam and some of the people in the
cast I was very close with a lot of cast
just because I worked pretty close with
them oh gosh Chris Lowell Wyatt Russell
who's doing very well he was just in
everyone everybody wants some mmm he's
Kurt Russell son and Goldie Hawn son
mm-hm
halt isn't that movie oh uh Aimee
Teegarden she was in Friday Night Lights
she's very nice too she was the coach's
son in Friday night coach's son Oh
daughter daughter
oh no ap no she's not like that she's
the coach's daughter yeah yes Friday
Night Lights is the show that I just
like like to have on in the background
of everything like I've watched it like
three times all the way through it's
like one of the best shows in the whole
world highly recommend Alex plays a
cocky student and a couple of them Wow
please watch I might get paid for that
at some point - shout-out to Friday
Night Lights yes oh this is good I like
shouting out it's gonna be fun um okay
well we have teased Miley Cyrus so yeah
I know
so much um okay so I'm friends with Liam
I can't wait to hear the story Miley has
just believed they are engaged at this
point like very close to becoming
engaged okay but so I work for this
producer and like basically half my job
for that summer is she just showed up to
hang out she'd shot this movie with Demi
Moore in Detroit the year the summer
prior so while I was working on scream
she had done this movie with Demi Moore
in Detroit so she liked liked Michigan
and liked hanging out so she would just
come and hang out on set all day and
also her fiance was yeah pretty correct
okay all those connections like really
lately I know like what anyone tell her
to leave probably not they'd be like
okay I mean I have so many Miley Cyrus
stories from that summer but I'm not
sure which one you're talking about to
be totally sure please I would like to
hear a little bit of so this I remember
this is like right before she kind of
she was a bad girl she was still nice of
course she was about yeah yeah so she
had long hair but I remember she had
gotten caught smoking a cigarette and
the paparazzi like went crazy
and put that out there Disneyland yeah
yeah exactly
she got an equal she got an equal sign
tattooed on her middle finger and so she
had but she had wandered off and no one
knew where she was when she was getting
a tattoo and I was like my job to go
find her like my boss said came up to me
he's like we're gonna find Miley like
where's Miley and I was like didn't know
that I didn't know that was part of this
whole thing but I will go find her and
so I remember running around this town
called it's the way any very late at
nights we're on night shoots and like
running all over town trans people have
you seen Miley Cyrus and then like I
finally found her a tattoo shop and she
said something like hey y'all what y'all
doing she was very like oh hey what's up
how's it going yeah but she I mean she
was cool she was always very nice to me
do you like I was like oh no we need to
go can't be here
you can't just be wandering around the
streets of it wasn't getting the tattoo
on her middle finger though she was
getting yeah she was she was getting
that tattoo yeah yeah I remember that
very distinctly because it exploded on
social media and I remember thinking to
myself like that's so why
that he was there for you right but also
like she's just wandering or she doesn't
care she hadn't thought this through at
all like she just kind of went to this
place and got this tattoo which is
awesome
like cool for her but like she just made
this split-second decision and then it's
everywhere like it's all over the news
which I remember thinking like oh that's
insane
well speaking of insane things Alex I
also have a list of things that you've
done very recently oh my gosh I'm gonna
tease that list though because I want to
go back to when I first hired you yeah
which at this point is like three years
ago I pulled up the email that's good
from May 21st 2014 so I had posted for a
production assistant on staff me up comm
shout-out and you had answered I emailed
you back I asked if you wanted to talk
you said quote absolutely exclamation
point yeah we talked I hired you
previous to that you know we had another
PA also named Alex yeah how do you feel
about that how did you feel at the time
did um I was fine with I remember link
came up to me and he was like trying to
set up my email this is a back one we
did everything there was like what five
of us yeah so this is old studio that
was like a weird like apartment half
medical situation was the best yeah
there was good times but so linkit came
up to me he's like well I need to set up
an email for you but you know we already
have an Alex one so I guess you can just
take that one best-case scenario for
Lincoln with the same name so he doesn't
have to remember the next person's name
because that's like a runner joke with
Linc is that he'll be like my name is
Alex and he'll be like Greg and you're
like no Alex which is so funny the first
week but you're three it's tough like
it's so rough when he comes up and says
that stuff to me now
just kidding it doesn't do that very
much okay so three years later here we
are
yeah at some point we brought my gun
you know you moved up to production
coordinator might came on as a PA mm-hmm
when Mike first came on question
question I'm so excited to talk about
this that's great because Mike was very
Mike ish at the time yes he hasn't
changed yet um so a lot of his PA duties
he just seemed he seemed very constantly
upset about yeah everything but yeah I
think for us both to understand that he
things yeah yeah so I knew like yeah
he's just kind of a very dry kind of a
dude do you know how I came to be here
though you might want to say this for
your your podcast with cuz I don't
remember I have the worst memory um so I
didn't pull up that email exchange yeah
yeah I have a great email exchange with
Mike but so I hired Mike because the old
Alex who used to work here had put up a
posting for interns and people on our
old Facebook and so that email address
was up and it was like oh if you need to
if you want to apply for this internship
you can't just email me at Alex blank
blank blank and so his old email was
mine just like I said like link it done
and so people who are pretty savvy could
find that pose and then email me and so
Mike had wait what do you mean people
who are pretty savvy you have to go way
back through all those Mike went like a
year back onto rhettandlink smaller than
that yeah yeah exactly
Wow and somehow found that email and
from the old Alex and then had emailed
me asking about internships but in his
email he included a script
starring both rhett and Link which he
will hate me for finding oh I totally
remember that yeah which I bet I could
find remember you telling me
about that and it was insane it's like
the most insane scribble but uh you know
what Mike can talk about that when he
comes on it is like oh it's genuinely
like the most insane we read it out loud
yeah we all read it and I was like just
like all that fanfic that we read yeah
we read it but it was nuts and I was
like this is so insane No and everyone
was like no don't call that dude like
that's insane and I was like yeah we
need like we got a million emails being
like can I can we work there
I'm like yeah and I remember laughing so
hard and then I brought Mike in a week
later and then like he's but was that a
joke what bring it it wasn't a joke oh
yeah it was a joke
I mean it was very clearly way over this
happened very Mike like I know Mike now
so I understand what he was doing but
back then I was like this is hilarious
this is absolutely insane like I have to
just see what's going on with this
person which we did I kept checking in
on him being like I think he might be
miserable yes I think he might hate
everything to do yeah he had a horrible
time when I first moved here I know
there's like so many things going around
but he's you know he's a very his car
got broken in and it broke down the
transmission brooked I mean he didn't
have a little like a mattress for a
while biscuit but my point bringing up
Mike is that like you guys are real-life
best friends at this point and so there
was a transition between getting that
email with that script that was
ridiculous yeah and then thinking that
Mike literally hated everything and then
to where we are today I mean so so you
you guys started working you really
started bonding on good mythical crew
yeah yeah yeah a point like Mike it's so
strange to think about now because like
we're we do everything and we're like I
don't we're partnering we're partners in
like every aspect of our life
we're friendship partners and business
partners and all kinds of partners in
every aspects of all I mean you don't
have to say all kinds of partners
because that kind of you know open the
doors ya know but at one point Mike
works for me like directly for me I
would tell Mike what to do every day
like you know and it's weird to think
about like it's just so far at one point
his role kind of changed and it was like
we were just splitting everything 5050
with what we're doing
and we now that's what we do anyways so
yeah it kind of developed slowly but
yeah we started we started doing the
crew stuff and like that's where I guess
we discovered our friendship because I
feel like I was recently looking at the
playlist
um about like an hour ago and it's funny
to me the things that you've done yeah
um
including you got your blood sucked by a
leech
my worst fear the only fear I have
really this all I'm scared of was
leeches but now that you've done it yeah
I really care okay okay that's like the
only thing he would ask me like when
we're trying to do the show they're like
what are you scared of and I was like
leeches I'll mess with leeches man and
it's true I still I still don't like him
but that was like my biggest fear so
we're just thinking about that to me was
it was in that woman's house yeah that
was insane like that's the scariest
that's the scariest she was like you're
not gonna like you're right uh-huh yeah
she was scary
I don't know it's great yeah she was
great she was another great shout out to
leech lady you built a cheese baby
fountain yeah that was awesome I I think
in that episode I you reveal it to me
yeah and you were like oh we can't use
that I was genuinely you impressed
genuinely impressed by your ability to
build that baby peeing cheese I was the
puking puking yeah in my memories yeah
it all blurs together um
you spent a full day gathering horse
poop yeah yep I think we'll leave that
one
I think we were like we just pray see
back on them date back in the day we
used to like do stuff with real reckless
abandon so we were like let's go to a
ranch well Ron there will steal some
horse poop and run off and that's what
we did like you said back in the day a
year me tall is not exactly that yeah
things like that yeah or of that that's
pretty much what it is
this one I feel like there was a
boundary that might have been crossed in
this in this oh I know it is really I
that's a long I mean it could be
anything but you drank LA River water
and then and you went into the river
yeah I swam in it nude yeah and I
exposed myself yeah there's some
blurring that had to be done yeah shout
out to those editors it was been I think
I remember Matthew be Matthew was not
into the hues like whoever had to blur
it was upset with me understandably I
get it
that was not safe no um you wore a
diaper to a Power Rangers convention
yeah that was good and people need to
watch that more good yeah that's good
you took a miniature horses temperature
rectally rectally is the part I was
implying but we've since worked with
those miniature horses so I feel like
that's not as big of a deal no we're
cool I just started with that one
because that one doesn't seem as bad
anymore
no yeah great grow the mini horse people
I'm sorry keep you in general and girl
great I think it girl the many horse
people I said those guys are great yeah
the woman yeah are the horses
all of them there what's the woman's
name Jean Jean she's awesome shout out
to her those people are for real amazing
she is really amazing great
um and then for some reason last on my
list cuz there's a whole long list and
if
you guys have not watched all the old
condensed milk rep suits
I just you have got to shout out to
those episodes and yeah we'll touch more
on 10 feet tall but I also we were in my
office looking for something to do that
was related to Gina episode the episode
was about hot dogs and I googled and
happened upon people swallowing the
whole hot dogs and you attempted that
yeah which like there's some times when
I'm reviewing your episodes where I like
literally tear laughing so hard and it's
not it's not it's always when you're
struggling I know that's like the
struggle is so real like so hard I got a
one of the baby ones yeah yeah but I
also should projectiled one out with
like the wildest noise ever it was like
that was a scary episode there's a lot
of iterations of episode but that's
where we got to and it was great yeah
yeah um
speaking of scary I mean let's talk a
little bit about ten feet tall yeah at
the time that this comes out we will be
really shooting buddy system even harder
yeah which I was supposed to I don't
even know how much I touched on I said
that we're shooting buddy system but um
but gosh boy is there a lot going on
yeah you so you are just a blur I know
we talked about you running but it's
true it's true ran in ran in here gonna
run out thank you um but one of my
favorite ten feet all episodes that came
out fairly recently a little bit further
back by the time this comes out is the
teddy bear yeah episode yeah and based
on that episode we kind of we've come up
with other fighting based episodes so
those episodes are gonna be out around
this time you got shot in the nethers
the nethers and you also hurt your hand
being shot at by
another ball yeah I noticed this stuff
never happens to Mike though isn't that
weird isn't that so strange how that
happens bizarre but literally every time
horrible bad stuff happens to me but
it's good it's always recover and we're
always safe like we always people talk
about how we do stuff around cars
yeah a that's not safe that's not good
we shouldn't do that stuff but we do
we're getting really lucky every so far
so good
yeah the point of me saying what my
favorite episode yeah has been as of
late was to ask you what your favorite
episode has been and or what you're
looking forward to and just talk a
little bit more about 10 feet tall and
yeah I mean we talked about Mike and i's
friendship and in kinda that show all
has like blossomed out of our friendship
and like we're very strange i think
people probably have cotton on to that
and so you know we've been given the
go-ahead to just basically do whatever
would you agree with that it's just like
you know within reason yeah yeah I mean
I still just check out you know like oh
yeah yeah okay yes video before it goes
out the title thumbnail but yeah I mean
pretty much whatever you want yeah yeah
like within some reason but that's like
an amazing opportunity like that's crazy
like people don't get to do that but um
I don't know about it what my favorite
episode is probably I think I like the
teddy bear one too just were having so
much fun it was so fun and our process
for that episode was like oh well get
them and we'll figure it out and it's
like when you have that much leeway to
kind of figure it out on your own and
like you're working through it with your
friend and it's awesome it was so fun
like we did not have beat it out I'll
throw trashcan at Mike we didn't have
the fact that Mike was gonna throw a
dummy at me yeah it's insane the stuff
that we did and it was so fun and that's
kind of you know we're trying to find
our way so I think and that's kind of
the thing that we're moving forward with
us like we have fun together and when we
get to
you know be wild and be ourselves that's
the best best episodes I think yeah I
mean when we were first talking about
transitioning away from good mythical
crew and starting this whole new show we
had a couple meetings where we were like
okay what are the let's come up with
some episode ideas and they have to have
this criteria and rhettandlink and I
were sitting down right like what do we
what do we want to see Mike and Alex do
and there was kind of a it was it was
very hard for us to think of things for
you guys so then when we sat down with
you guys and we were like well what do
you guys think it's funny and what do
you want to do got hot dog stands came
back and talked to us you had like a
list of 30 ideas that we would have
never thought of and we're like yes yes
yes that's very mega Natalie well you
guys know us very very well at this
point especially you see we I'm
old-school at this place is crazy
you were even though your emails even
older than you it's true I sent it in
vitro I don't know in the womb no your
email address oh yeah yeah that earlier
I thought you meant I wasn't born yet
which doesn't make any sense well Alex
thank you so much for being my first
guest
yes at the end of ear biscuits episode's
guests get to sign the table I want to
extend the same courtesy to you
unfortunately I'm gonna have to ask you
to sign underneath the table because I
that's where I feel like the mythical
crew should be signing yeah you you
understand no yeah I get it yeah Harley
Harley Mortensen takes up a lot of room
so it's like you know and he might be
coming back and we need another space
for him to take up equally yes oh maybe
maybe final I'm kind of bummed out
wasted on Harley but great guys still
though love you all right I'd like to
watch you do this so much harder than
you think it is
um you do you notice another signature
under there right yeah it's the whole
that way but he wasn't asked to sign
right I don't know the story of that I
do because I remember we were we were
moving this table in and saw that out
the old Alex had signed Thunder Neath
what is it I mean Ben Ben had told me
that he had asked them about him he was
just like yeah like that was my final
goodbyes so he probably can keep that in
the episode what keeping that in the
episode and old Alex this is a final to
you thank you so much thank you it's
been a beautiful three years I can't
wait for more and you are a fearless
leader and
[Music]